[Música]
sexta jornada de la Cumbre climática de
la ONU que se desarrolla en Egipto
marcada por la presencia de Estados
Unidos en su intervención el presidente
Se comprometió a ayudar en la transición
energética y a reducir las emisiones de
carbono para el año 2030
las tropas de Ucrania retoman el control
de la ciudad de gerson tras La retirada
del ejército ruso sin embargo
Moscú mantiene que su salida militar no
cambia el estatus de la región
anexionada a Rusia
primer día de la Cumbre de la asean
centrada en la crisis de myanmar los
líderes de la asociación de Naciones del
sudeste asiático acordaron comprometerse
con los grupos de la oposición frente a
la ausencia de aplicación del plan de
paz negociado en abril del año pasado
con la junta militar que tomó el poder
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de France 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
mateu y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
comenzamos esta edición en Egipto porque
el presidente de Estados Unidos Joe
biden estuvo finalmente en charmel Jake
donde se desarrolla la Cumbre climática
de las Naciones Unidas Poco después de
llegar a Egipto se reunió con el
presidente abdelfatá al sisid y
acordaron discutir la asociación
estratégica de los dos países y los
problemas de seguridad regional mientras
que en su alocución en la co27 el líder
estadounidense Se disculpó por la salida
de su país del acuerdo de París durante
la administración de la ex presidente
Donald Trump además vayan Se comprometió
a ayudar en la transición energética y a
reducir las emisiones de carbono para el
año 2030 sin embargo no concretó ninguna
medida en referencia al fondo de daños y
pérdidas que pide el sur global
escuchemos parte de su intervención
primeros días en el cargo de
administración lideró una agenda
bastante intrépida para enfrentarse a la
crisis climática y la seguridad
energética en el país y en todo el mundo
inmediatamente
nos encontramos al acuerdo de París
creamos bastantes reuniones climáticas y
restablecimos
me disculpo si me descubro por haber
salido del acuerdo establecimos
un foro de grandes economías para
pedirle al países en todo el mundo que
aumenten sus ambiciones climáticas el
año pasado el 26 en Glasgow los Estados
Unidos ayudaron a cumplir con un
compromiso crítico que llevaría dos de
tres tercios de producto interno bruto a
limitar el crecimiento del calentamiento
global
estamos comprobando que una política
climática buena es buena económicamente
también es un buen fundamento
para un crecimiento económico inclusivo
resiliente está ayudando a progreso en
el sector privado Progreso en todo el
mundo
y el total de las acciones que
administraciones está tomando por
Estados Unidos en camino a cumplir con
las metas de la cortezas de reducir las
emisiones al 50%
de aquí a 2030
a pesar de los compromisos expresados
por vaiden en la Cope las elecciones de
medio término del pasado martes pueden
tener un peso determinante en la
política climática de Estados Unidos en
diálogo con France 24 la abogada
comunitaria y ambiental Ruth Santiago
analiza como una victoria republicana en
el congreso influiría en el
posicionamiento de Washington ante la
crisis climática recordemos que los
resultados definitivos de las
legislativas dependen todavía de Nevada
Arizona y Georgia
una mayoría republicana en la cámara de
representantes de los Estados Unidos
podría tiene un potencial para hacer
algo desastroso verdad de no
no lograr que los Estados Unidos cumpla
sus metas de reducir las emisiones como
dijo el presidente Noé a nivel de 2000
por debajo del nivel del 2005
Eso es así A menos a menos que
prevalezca verdad algún motivo de
negocios dentro de los contribuyentes al
partido republicano que les convenga no
hacer una transición
es decir si a los contribuyentes del
partido republicano les conviene por
razón de negocio o algún lucro
convertir otra transformar
hacia
energías renovable pues entonces podría
ser que ellos permitan ese tipo de
transición pero claro sería energías
renovable de casi siempre a escala
industrial y No necesariamente a escala
comunitaria verdad desde el punto de
vista de de las personas y las
comunidades que puedan tener empoderarse
con relación al sistema eléctrico de
manera que puedan por ejemplo generar
sobre los techos de sus viviendas
utilizando placas solares y
inversores y baterías para para hacer lo
que conocen se conoce como prosumidores
números y pasivos consumidores sino
participar activamente en la red
vamos ahora con noticias de la guerra en
Ucrania porque el ejército ucraniano
retoma la localidad de gerson tras La
retirada total de las tropas rusas
decenas de civiles celebraron la llegada
de las fuerzas ucranianas recordemos que
jerson era la mayor urbe bajo control de
Moscú y un punto Geo estratégico de la
Guerra sin embargo Rusia mantiene que la
salida militar de la ciudad no cambia su
estatuto de zona anexionada según Moscú
tras su retirada de jerson No quedan
tropas rusas al oeste del sistema
fluvial niéper que divide Ucrania el
mayor repliegue organizado de las tropas
rusas desde que abandonaron la región de
kiev ha sido celebrado por el presidente
ucraniano como una victoria para su país
Hoy es un día histórico estamos
recuperando el sur de nuestro país
estamos recuperando gersones a partir de
ahora nuestros Defensores están en las
afueras de la ciudad Solo falta un poco
más y luego empezar a entrar pero las
unidades especiales ya están en la
ciudad
quiero hacer una mención especial a esos
soldados mercenarios y colaboradores
rusos que fueron abandonados en gerson y
otras ciudades del sur la única
posibilidad de que ustedes se salven es
Rendirse al cautiverio ucraniano de
conformidad con la ley y las normas
internacionales
y precisamente desde la invasión rusa de
Ucrania el suministro de combustible a
la Unión Europea por parte de Rusia
disminuyó un 80%. Alemania la mayor
economía Europea y altamente dependiente
del garroso prevé largos apagones por lo
que sus ciudadanos se preparan para
enfrentar una situación inédita para
muchos Rafael Pérez nos cuenta más
lo que alguna vez solo vieron en la
ficción hoy es una amenaza real a la que
deben acostumbrarse quedarse a oscuras
Y es que los alemanes están recurriendo
a cursos de capacitación para saber cómo
actuar en caso deberse en un apagón
si se va la electricidad Entonces ya
nada funcionará y Debemos entender Qué
significa realmente nada funciona eso va
desde Llamar a los servicios de
emergencia hasta ver las luces de la
calle apagadas y eso representa estar a
oscuras como la boca de un lobo en la
calle y luego en las casas también está
completamente oscuro y nada funciona los
cursos se ofrecen de manera gratuita por
la organización alemana de ayuda y
bienestar amparados por la agencia
gubernamental de protección civil y
asistencia en Casos de desastre la
crisis energética mundial impulsada por
la invasión rusa Ucrania y las sanciones
impuestas por la Unión Europea Moscú
complican el abastecimiento de
combustible al viejo continente
hace tres generaciones la gente sabía lo
que era estar sin electricidad hoy nos
damos cuenta de que apenas podemos
funcionar sin electricidad así que
puedes verlo rápido que se apoyan y
cambian las cosas y sin electricidad las
cosas cambian prácticamente se paralizan
no moriremos por eso pero la vida diaria
se paraliza
con las reservas de combustibles casi
llenas Alemania espera evitar los
apagones gracias a una inusual calidad
imperante lo que contribuye al ahorro
vamos a Francia porque las 230 personas
a las que Italia impidió desembarcar en
sus costas llegaron al puerto francés de
Tulum Este viernes lo hicieron a bordo
del barco de rescate Ocean viking un
tercio de las personas rescatadas
permanecerán en centros administrativos
de Francia el resto de personas
rescatadas serán dirigidas a otros
países de la Unión Europea mientras la
falta de alternativas migratorias
legales para llegar y permanecer en
territorio comunitario continúa en el
fondo de la cuestión Francia acusó a
Italia de responder de forma inhumana a
una situación de emergencia humanitaria
y en el primer día de cumbre de la asean
la asociación de Naciones del sudeste
asiático los líderes se acordaron
comprometerse con los grupos de la
oposición de myanmar frente a la
ausencia de aplicación del plan de paz
negociado en abril del año pasado con la
junta militar leorel tiene los detalles
Un año más La silla de nyanmar estuvo
vacía en la apertura de la Cumbre de la
Ocean los líderes militares Siguen sin
poder asistir a las reuniones
importantes de la organización y se
arriesgan a ser excluidos
definitivamente si no empiezan a aplicar
el plan de paz acordado en abril de 2021
dentro del bloque Indonesia ha sido una
de las principales voces pidiendo una
acción más dura contra la junta
demianmark
Indonesia está profundamente
decepcionada la situación en mi armar
está empeorando no hay avances
significativos en la implementación del
consenso de los cinco puntos y luego no
hay compromiso de la junta no debemos
permitir que la situación en mi amar
defina a la Asia
mi hermana ha entrado en una espiral de
conflictos sangrientos desde que los
militares derrocarón el gobierno de
anson suquía en febrero de 2021 el
secretario general de Naciones Unidas
Antonio Gutiérrez condenó de nuevo la
escalada de violencia y la crisis en
materia de Derechos Humanos que vive el
país
los ataques indiscriminados contra la
población civil pueden constituir
crímenes de guerra según el derecho
internacional reitero mi llamamiento a
las autoridades de myanmar para que
liberen a todos los presos políticos y
pongan en marcha inmediatamente un
proceso para volver a la transición
democrática Este es el único camino
hacia la paz
las potencias occidentales han impuestos
sanciones a la junta mientras la
violencia se ha intensificado en las
últimas semanas con mortíferos ataques
militares aéreos contra objetivos
civiles
Estados Unidos continúa pendiente de los
resultados definitivos de las elecciones
de medio término del martes la atención
en estos momentos está puesta sobre el
avance del conteo en Arizona y Georgia
que pueden decantar el control del
senado Cristóbal Vázquez nuestro
corresponsal en Washington nos amplía la
información
pues definitivamente en Arizona es donde
se está demorando la elección para
definir quién se queda con la mayoría en
cámara de representantes y senado de
hecho medios locales están diciendo que
Precisamente en Arizona quedan todavía
300.000 votos por contar sobre todo en
el condado de maricopa muy cercano a la
ciudad de Phoenix donde votaron muchas
personas y lo hicieron por correo pero
en vez de enviar ese voto por correo de
forma anticipada pues llevaron su sobre
el mismo día de la lección y esto ha
demorado el conteo en ese estado las
cosas están de la siguiente forma el
senado en este momento los demócrates
tienen 48 escaños los republicanos 49 en
el senado Precisamente lo que están
diciendo los pronósticos es que Nevada
pues va a ser un estado que van a ganar
los republicanos el republicano va a
ganar ese estado según las proyecciones
Arizona a pesar de que no se ha
terminado de contar la mayoría de los
votos le dan ese estado a los demócratas
al demócratas Kelly así entonces la cosa
quedaría dependiendo únicamente de lo
que pase en Georgia porque recordemos
que de haber un empate 50 escaños
republicanos 50 demócratas el voto el
escaño de la vicepresidenta Camila
Harris es el que le daría la mayoría
Entonces al partido demócrata en cuanto
a la cámara en este momento los
demócratas tienen aseguradas 200 4
sillas los republicanos 211 sillas están
muy cerca lograr esa cifra mágica de 218
votos sillas para lograr la mayoría y en
cuanto a gobernaciones 22 gobernaciones
han ganado los demócratas en esta
elección y 24 los republicanos hay que
Resaltar que ha habido cierta tensión en
internamente en el partido republicano
porque pues en tropa ha salido
públicamente a criticar a medios que lo
hayan apoyado durante su su sus últimos
años de política como es el Western pues
estos medios están
énfasis y están apoyando ahora aún más a
ROM de santis que se perfila como
precandidato presidencial y Donald Trump
pues ha lanzado varios ataques
públicamente al candidato y Burger dueño
de estos medios de comunicación lo que
argumentan los republicanos internamente
es que faltó más trabajo faltó más
seguimiento en el partido republicano y
que es hora ya de dejar la dependencia
de Donald Trump como líder del partido
y cerramos esta edición en París donde
se encontraron representantes del
oficialismo y de la oposición Venezolana
en el marco del foro para la paz
liderado por el presidente francés
Emmanuel macron el encuentro lo
protagonizaron el presidente de la
asamblea nacional de Venezuela Jorge
Rodríguez y el opositor Gerardo blaite y
además estuvo presenciado por los jefes
de estado de Colombia y de Argentina
Gustavo Petro y Alberto Fernández que
junto con macron abogaron por la
reanudación de los diálogos venezolanos
Muchísimas gracias por su atención sigan
con nosotros
[Música]